dan de studiemigratie
dat is de tweede wij
geven les in het engels en bijna alle universiteiten
dat betekent dat hele opleidingen zijn die
bijna alleen buitenlandse studenten hebben
er zijn zelfs universiteiten
die meer buitenlandse studenten
dan Nederlands studenten hebben
denk aan Maastricht
en we zijn dit jaar ook nog begonnen
met 1 beurs te betalen
die betalen ook 1 allereerste
maar wat gaan we daar tegen doen
Nederlands als voertaal en universiteit
en dus iedereen die geen Nederlands spreekt
hoeft niet meer te komen
nou als je de
als je Nederlands leert en
hier onderdeel wilt worden van de samenleving
kun je hier ook studeren
dus dat is geen enkel probleem
en universiteiten kunnen ook
af en toe lessen in het engels blijven geven
het is geen verboden taal
maar de standaardtaal
waar 1 lesgegeven wordt is je eigen landschap
vergeet ook niet dat is cultureel heel belangrijk
vraag me hoe het in Friesland gaat
als je 1 taal niet meer aan de universiteit
gebruikt en niet meer in de kunst en cultuur gebruikt
dan wordt het 1 streektaal met Allen
als je weet wat het is en u zegt als je
als je dat als je Nederlands
tot de voertaal maakt
dan zullen er veel minder studenten komen
dan komen er minder studenten uit het buitenland
dat is zo ja dat zul je stapsgewijs moeten doen
want 1 gedeelte van de docenten
heeft nu nog engels ons moedertaal
dus dat zou ik ook niet in 1 jaar
doen de hervorming
die gaat
door